you dude ce qu'ils écoutent aujourd'hui
se trouve sur pour guangzhou et massa
qui sépare les mêmes créateurs qui avait
fait le jeu baby sitter blood bfc partie
nouveau jeu on y va pupitres combo
présente sa fin car aucun screamer comme
ça on sera bien tranquille ya le soleil
qui est là pour nous rassurer bien
évidemment on adore alors ça sert tribu
pas un cas d'accident de voiture des
dons mégane
jeff est ce que ça va jeff je ne sens
plus mes jambes jeu d'acteur ou pas ne
t'en fais pas jeff je vais chercher de
l'aide ne va pas chercher de l'aide
on sait déjà croisé à plusieurs bandes
aide s'il te plaît ne va pas dans un
endroit glover un endroit tranquille
paisible ainsi le pire mal de set que
j'ai jamais eue il va vers son que je
frime et d'avoir une lampe torche dans
le coffre de la voiture
alors est-ce que je peux avoir le la
lampe torche et loué lampe torche et là
elle est là mais prend là bordel de
merde et sur eux ou espace à hiesse sûr
c'est une bonne nouvelle mais la musique
comme ça mais je vais te faire couper la
tête loi alors on à la lampe torche
comment l'allument à votre tasse à
l'allumer super l on y va power trio
massacres y ait un jeu pareil combattez
dans l'endroit le plus ghetto de cette
région voilà chercher de l'aide
un jeu qui n'est 12v quoi est ce qu'on
est sûr escalade simulator je ne mens
pas quand tu te trompes de l'aide là
sans déconner essien entre la gare c'est
un miracle ou var et c'est quoi ça on
dira nomme quoi on voudrait carbon one
est territoire et a disparu
oh là là ok tu crois dans un manoir
chelou avec un homme qui disparaît
devant nous bonjour je viens sans paie
mon copain d'enfance jeff est blessé
pourriez-vous l'aider s'il vous plaît je
fais beaucoup dream ans et où venait
avec quoi admirer ce merveilleux
couchers de soleil pendant que jeff
agonise
oh là là voilà lé l'entrée dans
l'entrepôt le plus chaud du monde cette
porte est ouverte
est ce qu'on y va non banon n'a qu'à
faire des pâtes éléments j'ai vraiment
apprécié oui on y va dans des de merde
alors créé en dehors mais déjà on
retient de qui dessinait sur le mur
qu'elle et lui quoi c'est la part des
roumains qui vient d'être verrouillé
bonjour est-ce que c'est ouvert cette
porte métallique c'est une porte
métallique fermé j'ai impression est
observée au c'est bête ça dans mes gars
tellement d'endroits où aller ont
regardé cette cave sombre et glauque
humides en bas je vais mourir j'aimerais
à cet endroit je le sais je veux
hyper du c'est quoi ce bordel la bayanne
chaise c'est bon signe ce souvent dire
que on ne peut rien faire en mode il ya
un truc qui brille ça a l'air d'être la
seconde partie d'un journal on le lit
allez le premier immeuble le soleil des
enfants orphelins a été construit par
russell mort un millionnaire excentrique
un inventeur qui a connu la gloire
durant la seconde guerre mondiale et un
peu plus tard qui a commis un suicide
après des allégations contre lui disant
qu'il avait abusé d'un enfant à
l'intérieur de leur folle hainard mais
c'est très bien voilà donc en gros on
est là dans cet endroit il ya un [ __ ]
de pédophilie kurde autour de nos moi
j'adore ceci ressemble la troisième
partie du journal on le lit allait se
qualifier du bâtiment est devenu une
série depuis l'ouverture
sept travailleurs ont perdu leur vie si
c'est très rassurant des accidents ont
été causés par des problèmes
d'équipement entre guillemets quelqu'un
fait ces coupures dans la corde
eh ben je suis très rassuré merci à tous
pour ces explications la mort je me
porte désormais mieux que jamais dans
cette gamme c'est la fête c'est la
fiesta geste à l'occar qu'on l'appelle
au ça me fait un [ __ ] de pincement au
coeur
un vase il put moyens on finit tous
ensemble radicaux la position foetus en
cas de danger on lie à rien mais j'ai
trop peur mon gars à bientôt
qu'est ce qu'on va devenir à la fin une
boîte de conserve pour sial qui leur ont
me c'est quoi ça c'est un étrange
endroit pour une flûte
je suis rassuré c'est bon un peu
ridicule ça m'a vraiment fait descendre
la pression les petits papiers de type
papier cette chanson que j'ai chanté en
cm2 à la chorale que j'avais une voix
très aiguë maintenant j'ai une voix
grave cass et je veux la merde sur ce
jeu
aux mondiaux
o le jura encore bonjour ton mec c'est
sérieux ça le mec il m'a sauté dessus
direct quoi j'ai fait du thé cuando
ainsi que du karaté du krav maga pendant
deux minutes
on faisait un exercice dans lequel on
devait faire le phoque et la baleine sur
le tapis aux intrus qui brille c'est
pour nous ça on dirait une clé un oui je
prends tu après une clé avec de la
peinture bleue dessus des escaliers qui
montent c'est bien avec une porte c'est
une porte qui veut ça mené a sorti ça la
porte est fermée
il y a trois verrous avec des éclats de
peinture dessus bleu vert et rouge donc
on a le bleu il nous faut le vert et le
rouge c'est parfait bon on va se balader
partout on va trouver ça vous en faites
pas bonjour je cherche deux clés s'il
vous plaît une rouge et une verte voilà
je vous aimerai beaucoup
mais c'est outre azur manga mais comment
voulez-vous finir un jeu pareil sondés
connaissent a l'air d'être une clé on
l'apprend vous venez d'obtenir la khl
avec de la peinture vert dessus wells
cela yann clay non ça un morceau de
recyclage à lui de on s'en fout il
arctique bordel la traque continue pour
les deux campeurs disparu dans les
propos nos montagnes
c'est intéressant je ne veux plus lire
cette merde ça suffit je pourrais pas
trouvé sur le journal de picsou géant
spirou magazine ça non il faut que ce
soit un article vraiment très très
effrayant quoi y'a plus la clé là dessus
[ __ ] mais quelle arnaque
je suis outré là je le sens bien là à le
bureau tourner avec rires je sens bien
s'il vous plaît jeff est en train de
décéder j'ai besoin d'une clé monsieur
quand j'ai le plus en plus y'a une
[ __ ] qu'est dans les chiottes et ce
que je vous l'avais pas dit ce cas pas
être deuxième clé dans un lavabo voit la
petite va en étoile est non jeunes types
si compact j'aimerais que tu m'aides a
trouvé la clé en échange d'un petit
massage ou des cervicales qui va te
faire du bien si tu es d'accord je te
prie d'envoyer 8 7 8 aux 90 12 12 offre
facturée 1 euro 34 par sms à voile à la
blague pour la détente on l'appelle
finalement classé la capsule ou là dans
laquelle on était juste avant qu'elle va
y aller on va s'amuser
ok j'ai fait le tour y avait pas de
couteau dans n'importe quoi c'est un
scandale je suis révolté monsieur
m'entendais vous appartenez dans
laquelle chose dans laquelle on était au
début à mon avis à les deux clés restant
dedans il y en a une à les tâches duo et
une dans cette cave et deux dans cette
cave pardon là bas c'est la cave on y va
juste après il faut déjà contre la
première clé ou alors les 300 tête dans
la cave alors fait demi-tour dans le
câble adéquat c'est bon il est vrai pas
il travaille pour le 007 ce mec c'est
sûr les filles fait des filatures mieux
que personne
on y retourne cette cave on va trouver
les trois clés ok on va libérer jeff où
on a raison de l'acide dans la cave là
sur lequel on était au début de la vidéo
mais qu'est ce que c'est que cet
incident avait chaud fondre dans l'eau
je ne sais point à ckoi son endroit
glauque là qu'est ce qui se passe ici
bonjour les mousses vous êtes là pour
sauver d'edf c'est ça faisait des
pansements venez avec moi on va le
sauver tous ensemble a fait pas ça les
mouches au quai jobez un marteau et
quelques couteaux je ne pense pas que
c'est assez pour me défendre a donc dû
vous ma gueule ou quoi y'a des couteaux
cessa pas te permet de défendre non oh
lala média combien de meurtres ici mon
gars 18 meurtres au mètre carré bonjour
qu'est ce que c'est que ça juste de la
verrerie des items pour une petite
partie de thé entre amis ça squelette
qu'elle attend mais c'est un squelette
caire dans la cage mon gars me bats
je suis enfermé ici le mec c'est quoi
c'est quoi c'est quoi je suis enfin dans
une cage puis après dans une cage j'suis
à poil dans une cage avec la nef
mais non non non non laisse-moi laisse
moi mais voilà vingt ans ma vie est cool
dans 7 cas j'adore on est bien on y fait
quoi il a une personnalité ce qui va
faire non fermé d'écoles par regarde je
me suis donné devant toi c'est une
preuve d'amitié
ah oui le mec qui parle comme une
grenouille wahou [ __ ] il a joué les
[ __ ] et de chansons d'enfants qui fait
pas
on à dire des bien je devrais c'est
marrant parce que graphiquement ça en
dessous de plus un jeu d'horreur récent
mais pourtant dans l'ambiance et la
frayeur c'est au top quoi alors il est
vrai qu'on a pas réussi à trouver les
trois clés mais on a réussi à être
enfermés nu dans une cage c'est quoi le
vieux ne répondrai pas à cette question
s'il vous plaît merci d'avoir regardé un
certain sérieux attendant une prochaine
vidéo tient tout le monde
téléphone pis